you got to hear this one song it'll
change your life I swear
[Music]
Michael Knowles here your music Maven
you know on on this show I have delved
many times into hip hop hippity hop I've
delved into pop music I've gone through
all the different genre but I haven't
quite made it to country music until now
this is a song by Hardy featuring Laney
Wilson it's a song called wait in the
truck 26 million views and the song has
received some controversy apparently
because it depicts murder
take it away
[Music]
I got turned around some little town I'd
never been to before working my way
through a middle of June midnight
thunderstorm
there was something in my headlights to
stop me on a dime
she was scared to death so I said
climbing and then she climbed
[Music]
she was bruised Bruce broke from head to
toe with a tear in a blood stain shirt
she didn't tell the whole truth but she
didn't have to I knew what had happened
to her I didn't load her down with
questions that girl had been through
enough I just threw it in Drive looked
in those eyes and asked her where he was
an angel cause angels
[Music]
I'm just waiting in the truck
just put a pause here before we're
obviously moving into this new scene
I don't listen to a ton of country music
because I don't listen to a ton of pop
music generally I do like some old
country music I'll sometimes play it on
the guitar in the ukulele but something
that turns me off about modern country
music is it's very often sappy
saccharine sentimental kind of music you
know well if it's about a truck it's
usually you know driving in a truck
you know dreaming about my girl and I'm
coming back to you dirt road the cold
beer it's all this kind of really sappy
stuff and but this is not this this is
really the highest form of Folk Music
and Country Music telling which is this
really rich narrative that's telling you
a story it doesn't even go back to any
hook at any point in particular it's
just it's a kind of a chanted poem you
know I mean when you think back in
ancient Greece of the homeric tradition
or even Troubadour was coming through
you know from Provence or something out
of the Dolce steel Nuevo and the
province of poetry and people just
singing songs of love and Justice and
nights and fighting this is the the
modern version of of that kind of
tradition it's very engrossing okay keep
going
[Music]
I never found my
phone
[Music]
I'm just waiting the truck whoa
foreign
so now it like a good really good piece
of art like a nice theatrical piece it
raises a real moral question and it
raises that real moral question because
the Guy waits for the cops if the guy
didn't wait for the cops if he just got
the girl shows up kicks in a double wide
door shoots this bad wife beater in the
back of the head and then he drives off
and runs from the cops and hopes he
doesn't get caught that's a much less
morally rich and narratively Rich
question
because the the whole story is pitting
different
conceptions of Justice we are supposed
to
allow the Civil authority to execute
Justice we are not supposed to engage in
vigilantism
revenge is the Lord's and the Lord
appoints Civil Authorities to maintain
Law and Order and Justice that's why we
have a justice system so you do you have
no right to engage in vigilante justice
but it would seem the Civil Authority is
failing here we don't know if this woman
ever called the cops son the guy who
beats her up maybe she did maybe she
didn't cops clearly never sniffed around
and no one noticed that she had these
bruises on her face there was a failure
there to investigate and stop this guy
from beating his wife and and
furthermore let's say that he did get
arrested there's a further failure which
is not even really hinted at here in the
video but we know it because we live in
this system ourselves we're living in a
society the justice system
has failures especially today because we
like criminals off the hook so often so
okay let's say that the cops actually
did show up and they booked this guy for
beating his wife he might get out he
might get out on bail first of all
depending on what if he lives in some
stupid liberal State he might get out
immediately I've been waiting for this
day
but when the bullet hits the guy in the
back of the head she's not she's good
she's protected but because the
protagonist of the story recognizes it's
not that he he denies that revenge is
the Lords and the Civil Authority has
the right to execute justice so he waits
for the cops said okay book me I I
recognize that I violated some aspect of
the civil law I think I did it for a
higher Justice and a higher
understanding of the law but the the
it's yours civil authority to decide
what to do and so he goes up on trial
the current administration's New Year's
goals are to tax spend and turn a blind
eye to inflation if this is at odds with
your goals you're tired of the
government playing games with your
savings and your retirement plan then
you need to get in touch with the
experts at Birch gold today for over
five thousand years gold has withstood
inflation geopolitical turmoil stock
market crashes now you can own gold and
attack sheltered retirement account
Birch gold makes it easy to convert an
IRA or 401K into an IRA in Precious
Metals text nulls Canon wlas 298 9898 to
claim your free info kit on gold and
then talk to one of their precious
metals Specialists with an A plus rating
with a Better Business Bureau thousands
of happy customers and countless
five-star reviews you can trust Birch
gold to help protect your savings text
Knowles Canada be Les to 98 9898 and
protect yourself with gold today that is
Knowles Canada w-les to 98 98 98
today keep going
[Applause]
she still comes to see me from time to
time
it was worth the price to see a brighter
side of the girl I picked up that night
it might be
forever
ain't there
that's true but it's a whole hell of a
lot better than the price I sent him to
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
crazy truck
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
it's quite good
it's quite that's quite a good story
because and you see it especially with
that shot of her feet walking out of the
frame and then his feet Shackled up in
the orange jumpsuit and he walks back
into his cell and you recognize that
what he has done here is not liberated
everyone this is not just a happy story
where everyone gets exactly what he
wants he's just traded places with him
she was in a prison in this double-wide
trailer with her abusive husband and he
was free driving on the road then he
picks her up and his compassion is moved
such that it's not that it's not even
just that his sense of justice is moved
because I don't think that what he did
is just actually it's understandable but
I don't think it's just because I don't
think that vigilantism is defensible I
might have been moved to do the same
thing I think we all naturally feel that
longing but but it's really this sense
of compassion and love for this other
woman albeit through the lens of a
fallen world he says okay I'm just going
to switch places with you now you get to
be free and I'll be the one in prison
because what he does is unjust because
it is not his place to go kill this guy
Justice must be served and so he's going
to trade places with her and he's going
to be in there and he's probably never
going to get out it's not as though this
is just a happy love story and they go
get married or something like that he
just sets this woman free because he
can't bear
the Injustice of it I mean you see that
this is what ancient Greek tragedy is
about Antigone right Antigone is
probably the greatest example of this
where Antigone wants to bury her brother
her brother has been killed he's been
left out for the dogs she wants to give
her brother a proper burial but the
Civil Authority says no you will not
that body is going to stay out there for
the dogs and you are bound to obey me
the Civil Authority and so now she's
torn between two things the higher
justice of giving her brother a proper
burial but also her obligation to follow
the Civil Authority and those two things
come to a head and that's why it's a
great strategy and you see it here if
you were driving on the road in the
middle of the night you saw some woman
badly beaten and you knew that you could
end that and you knew that the guy who
did it deserved what he got
would you do we certainly would be moved
to do it the better way would be to just
work to perfect our system of justice so
that you didn't need to trade places
with her but if that were the only
option would you do it you might you
might do it even if it's not totally
just that's how tragedy works that's how
moral decisions are often made in the
world even though we know the ends do
not just good ends do not justify
immoral means ever that's what the libs
believe
but it's not just what the lips believe
that people we're all drawn to that
sometimes even people on the right we
have the sense that you know the reason
we can sleep peacefully at night is be
as rough men are willing to do bad
things out there on the edges that we
don't really need to see and that it's a
there's a very romantic view of that
it's not it's not ultimately good it's
not ultimately defensible this does not
excuse the kind of Machiavellian ends
ends justify the means kind of view of
things but it's very compelling it's
pretty good
[Music]